[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: Hello.
Today we'll be talking about how
to make your data in a bucket
public to everyone
on the internet.
This means that your data
will be readable to everyone
on the internet.
I've created a bucket
called tiny_homes.
In this bucket, I'll be
storing photos of tiny homes.
As you can see, right now,
all the images are private,
but I want to make
these images public
so people can access them.
So the first step is to open
the Cloud Storage Browser
in Google Cloud Console.
When we are in the bucket,
we can see all the files
that live in the bucket.
So to make a single file
public, what we want to do
is we want to click
the Actions menu, which
is the three little bars
to the side of the file.
We want to select
Edit Permissions
from the drop-down menu.
Then we want to
add a new entity.
The entity name should
be Public, then allUsers,
and then Reader, and
then just click Save.
And as you can
see, we have a link
that we can share
with anyone who
wants to view this specific
file in the bucket.
But let's say we want to make
all the images in this folder
public.
It would be tedious to do
the actions that we performed
earlier to every item in the
bucket, so what we can do
is we can click the
Edit Permissions button,
add a new member
called all_users,
set their role as Storage Object
Viewer in the Cloud Storage
section, and that's it.
You've made every image
in our bucket public.